tonight as inflation rises the economy
stalls the border spiraling way out of
control in the middle of a pandemic and
covert 19 mandates now there's talk
tonight oh we may have to push that back
the recognition that there are tens and
tens of thousands of crucial workers
that have decided they're not going to
agree with it regulations having no end
in sight biden's poll numbers plummeting
to the mid 30s and now yet another
all-time low according to gallup since
taking office in january biden's
approval rating has now plummeted a
whopping 27 percent with independence
other polls have his approval rating in
the mid 30s there's not a single thing
that joe biden and his administration
can claim as successful for you the
american people and now we have a frail
and a weak and a cognitive mess and a
deeply unpopular president desperately
trying to sell his insane build back
better new green deal socialism
socialism that he claims falsely that
won't cost a single penny lead us to say
it's not going particularly well take a
look no little expression time is money
as one computer said
if you're on the train and they say
portal bridge you know you better make
other plans
all right there you have it according to
biden we have to pass spill back better
socialism because quote as one computer
said
computer not commuter if you're on the
train and they say portal bridge you
know you better make other plans now
after stumbling and mumbling and
bumbling through his prepared remarks
biden once again told the same long
rambling debunk story about amtrak now
for the fifth time and he just keeps
lying take a look
and ange walks up to me and goes joey
baby he grabs my cheek and i thought the
secret service was going to blow his
head off
i said i swear to god true story he said
joey
i read in the paper
i read in the paper
you travel 1 000 to 1 million 200 000
miles on air force planes because they
keep meticulous tabs in it so the boys
and i figured out the retirement dinner
he said it traveled
2 million i think it was 180 but 2
million 200 000 miles
only problem is that never happened
according to multiple fact checkers
joe's story is not true at all and yet
here we are listening to the same long
bs for the fifth
time here and of course the biden
administration they have no problem
lying about anything and everything
remember mayorkis yeah the dhs secretary
lying about the border crisis calling
the mass migration this is only a
seasonal problem chen saki circling back
with the lie about the border crisis
migrants don't need to be tested for
covert they're not planning on staying
here very long and then she lied about
oh well yeah we're dispersing people all
over the country at 2 am and 4 am
in the middle of the night that's not
the middle of the night that would be
called um an early morning flight uh
i've flown a lot that's actually not
true and biden lying about covert 19
declaring that he could beat the virus
as president he told that lie a lot also
lying about leaving americans behind in
afghanistan 13 days before he did it
lying again about the number of
americans he abandoned we have a full
report tonight coming up on that but of
course biden is also lying about his
build back better new green deals social
spending proposal by saying the 3.5
trillion dollar price tag actually cost
zero dollars i'm not sure what
calculator he's using that's about the
biggest lie of all also promising not to
raise taxes on anyone making under four
hundred thousand dollars a year well
that's actually a couple so it's two
hundred thousand and according to the
joint committee on taxation the original
build back better new green deal
socialism would hit americans making
under fifty thousand dollars a year the
hardest with a sneaky provision
targeting those who deposit small sums
of money into their own bank accounts so
they can spy on you now democrats have
come up with a new idiotic tax scheme a
levy on unrealized gains in other words
phantom money money that you might make
in the future after you finally you get
money your money is taxed you invest
your money you buy stocks or some type
of other asset but don't worry the biden
administration is promising that only
the super wealthy will be affected this
is another lie take a look
i think what's under consideration is a
proposal that
senator wyden and the senate finance
committee have been looking at
that would
impose
a tax on unrealized capital gains
on liquid assets held by extremely
wealthy individuals
all right you really believe her because
according to democrats this would only
raise 30 billion dollars of the three
and a half trillion that they want in
new spending so will they extend this
new tax to institutional investors
meaning all of us in other words will
they include pension funds 401ks and by
the way what would happen if an asset
that they say is a capital gain
eventually depreciates or your stocks go
down i mean the market could have an
adjustment at any point right will the
government hand out billion-dollar
checks to billionaires during a
recession even the washington post is
trashing the plan saying quote biden's
latest tax the rich scheme would be an
unworkable and possibly unconstitutional
mess that's to say the least now
uh raises raises a ton of questions but
don't expect any coherent answers from
joe because today he bragged to a group
of preschoolers about his strategy
always avoid answering the press's
questions which he probably is the one
thing you could say he's successful at
take a look you know when you're
president you see all these people here
they're they're with you all the time
they get to ask you all kinds of
questions and you try to figure out how
you can avoid answering them sometimes
[Laughter]
anyway
i'm sure the kids got that joke joey
according to the rnc joe biden has not
held an official press conference in
over 100 days well we all know the
answer why he's not mentally or
physically capable of conducting a
lengthy presser forget about late
afternoon if you ever tried it at night
it would be an unmitigated disaster you
don't need a medical degree from harvard
to figure this all out biden is also
desperately trying to avoid being held
accountable for all of these many
self-inflicted crises that he caused
remember the economy is a disaster
because of him gas prices are spiking
dramatically because of him
energy dependence is back because of joe
not good for national security not good
for the economy there's a massive worker
shortage all because of joe biden there
are nationwide supply chain disruptions
because of joe biden
the afghanistan withdrawal was a
disaster one that could easily have been
preventable same with the southern
border in chaos because of him every
single one of these crises easily
preventable but joe biden and his
minders on the radical left are either
unwilling or unable to do the right
thing and coming up a new report on the
latest migrant caravan yep they're
they're making their way right to our
border just to be processed in and
dispersed in an early morning 4 a.m
flight as jinsaki says and we have a
shocking new development tonight out of
afghanistan pay attention to this we'll
have it in a minute hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else